the last time you did me and you were
very good you did my laughs very well
yeah do you do lots of people are you
one of those actors no yeah yeah but I
mean I think I think I think a lot of a
sub here don't we I mean no it's either
music or it's oh it's it's bits voices
or tons of voices I mean you know ice
and macaroon with dictaphones at school
for ages and just you know
interpretations impersonations of people
and great characters and it's just sort
of having an ear it's part of what we do
I guess I mean even if it's not a real
person just to imitate or have empathy
with a a state or a human being of any
gem you were doing Chewbacca during the
clip what I'm with the two back of thing
just natural magic that's one of my
favorites you back a moment it's just
that can I take you back
you don't even shopton to be backup sir
and I said that I do my own makeup but I
can tell you and real diva would never
do her own makeup that part is it also
ridiculous
now can we be honest marry the final bit
of the final those wedding cakes they
were piss-poor weren't